Our genetic similarities can do more than just connect
individuals. The broader scope of ancestry is about populations
and evolution. For example, I know that I was
born in United States, but if I trace my
relatives back several generations, I would find that I
have a strong connection to Northern Europe. In fact,
when I look at my 23andMe ancestry report, I
find that I'm 98% European. I can zoom in here.
And I can see what percentage of Northern Europe
I am, and then it maps mainly to the British
and Irish isles. We can also look at the
same information in Chromosome View. And what I notice is
that even though me and my genes currently reside
in the United States. Apparently, my genes have traveled over
space and time all the way from Northern Europe,
look how much of my genome is from Northern Europe.
And specifically regions from Britain and Ireland. A much
smaller percent of my genome we can see is from
Sub Saharan African and a much even smaller region, a
teeny, tiny region right. Is from South Asia. When we
think about genes and alleles moving over time in
a geographic space, we get a new perspective on our
past. And it can also be a lot more meaningful
when you have somebody who doesn't have quite the homogenous
genetic background that I have. Here we're
looking at an example from someone named
Roy King. And we can see they have an amazing history, 51% from Sub-Saharan
Africa 43.3% European, about 1.8% East Asian
and Native American, and 0.2% South Asian. Wherever this individual is
currently living, their genes are truly from all over the world.